GOT QUITE A LARGE CROWD WILLING
TO TESTIFY ANGST TO TESTIFY IN
ASSEMBLY WOMAN GONZALEZ IS HERE
SAUL I'D LIKE TO WAIT JUST A
COUPLE MINUTES UNTIL WE GET ONE
OTHER PERSON WILL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. DID I SAY SIMPLY.
OKAY THIS IS THE SENATE IS. THE
.
FIVE THE FAMOUS IN HANDSOME IS
HE JUST DESCRIBED HIMSELF
SENATOR HERTZBERG IS HERE SO
WE'LL GET STARTED AS A SUB
COMMITTEE. WE ONLY HAVE ONE
MATTER BEFORE US TODAY WE HAVE
A CA FOURTEEN. THE ONE GOOD
SAUCES IS WITH US SO IF YOU'D
LIKE TO BEGIN. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN. AND MEMBER HERTZBERG
EASY FOURTEEN IS SIMPLY A
RESOLUTION THAT ASKS THE VOTERS
WHETHER THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SHOULD ENSURE THAT
ALL WORKERS WHO PERFORM SUPPORT
SERVICES AT THE UC ARE FOR THE
SAME EQUAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY STANDARDS AS YOU
SEE EMPLOYEES BEYOND PROVIDING
WORLD CLASS INSTRUCTION AND
RESEARCH AT ITS CAMPUSES
MEDICAL CENTERS THE UC IS THE
STATE'S THIRD LARGEST EMPLOYER
IN AS AN ANCHOR TO THE
COMMUNITIES IN WHICH IT
OPERATES. IN RECENT YEARS UC'S
OUTSOURCING ESTIMATED SEVEN
THOUSAND TO NINE THOUSAND
SUPPORT SERVICE JOBS WHAT THE
SAME TIME INCREASING THE NUMBER
OF HIGHLY PAID ADMINISTRATORS
TO APPROXIMATELY EIGHT THOUSAND
ONE HUNDRED THIS RESULTED IN
ANNUAL ADMINISTRATE PAYROLL
COST INCREASE OF APPROXIMATELY
SIXTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS THIS
MATCH IS THE AMOUNT THAT THE UC
HAS PREVIOUSLY ESTIMATED IT%
WOULD COST TO OFFER OUTSOURCED
WORKERS. THE FULL PROTECTION
CITY COMPLEMENT OPPORTUNITY
STANDARDS ENJOYED BY YOU SEE
EMPLOYEES. IN RESPONSE TO
CONCERNS RELATE TO THE NEED FOR
FLEXIBILITY TO HANDLE I THEIR
MEDICAL EMERGENCIES OR AN
ANTICIPATED NEEDS ANYWHERE IN
THE UC SYSTEM WE TOOK
AMENDMENTS AND ASSEMBLY THAN
CORPORATION UC'S CURRENT
POLICIES FOR USE OF TEMPORARY
PER DIEM UNIVERSITY EMPLOYEES.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THE WORK ON THE
ANALYSIS HERE WHICH RAISES AN
IMPORTANT QUESTION. WHY THIS
APPROACH VIA A CA AS OPPOSED TO
THE STATUTORY PROPOSALS MADE
INFORMACIóN ARE LARA'S
PREVIOUS BILLS. THE ANSWER IS
SIMPLE IT'S MONEY. THE PREVIOUS
PROPOSALS ADDED COST TO THE
EXISTING CONTRACTS THOSE BILLS
RAISED WAGES AND BENEFITS WOULD
INCREASE THE COST OF UC'S
EXISTING CONTRACTS. THE
ANALYSIS AND HOPEFULLY WE HAVE.
THE WE GIVE THAT TO HIM IN
FRONT OF YOU BY MICHAEL GYMNAST
OF DIRECTOR OF FINANCE FOR THE
LAST REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR
CONCLUDES THAT THE ADDITIONAL
PAYROLL COSTS IN A CA FOURTEEN.
ARE MORE THAN OFFSET BY A
REDUCTION IN OVERHEAD COSTS IN
THE EXISTING CONTRACTS MR
GYMNAST STATES WE CONCLUDE THAT
YOU SEE CAN ABSORB THE COST OF
A CA FOURTEEN WITHIN THE
AMOUNTS CURRENTLY BUDGETED FOR
EXISTING CONTRACTS. MR GENETIC
CONCLUSION IS SUPPORTED BY
STATE AUDITOR'S FINDING IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THAT SERVICE
CONTRACT WORKERS COULD COST
MORE THAN UNIVERSITY EMPLOYEES
DEPENDING ON WHETHER ONE
CONSIDERS ALL COSTS INCLUDING
OVERHEAD. SENATORS AC FOURTEEN
WILL PROTECT SERVICE WORKERS AT
THE UC FROM POLICIES THAT
PRODUCE ECONOMIC RACIAL AND
GENDER DISCRIMINATION NEITHER
THE LEGISLATURE NOR THE
GOVERNOR CAN ADDRESS A
SYSTEMATIC INEQUITIES THAT
OCCUR DUE TO THE UC'S AUTONOMY
UNDER ARTICLE NINE OF THE
CONSTITUTION. HOWEVER ARTICLE
TO GIVE THE LEGISLATURE THE
POWER AND RESPONSIBILITY TO
ALLOW VOTERS THE OPPORTUNE TO
PROTECT VULNERABLE RESIDENTS OF
OUR STATE. I SIMPLY ASK THAT
YOU ALLOW THE VOTERS TO DECIDE
WHETHER LOW INCOME SERVICE
WORKERS THAT YOU SEE THOSE WHO
CLEAN THE TOILETS MOW THE LAWN
SERVE OUR FOOD AND CLEAN THE
BED PANS. SHOULD ENJOY THE SAME
STANDARDS ENJOYED BY YOU SEEM
IS DURING THAT SAME MARK MY
WITNESSES HERE TO TESTIFY.
LABOR ONE SECOND LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM BEFORE WE
LOSE ONE SO. I'M SECRETARY IF
YOU WOULD CALL THE ROLL NUMBER
YOUR NUMBER HERE NIELSEN.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HERE LEYVA
LEYVA HERE STERN. OKAY ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE A QUORUM. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING CATHERINE
WEINBERGER PRESIDENT OF APPS ME
THIRTY TWO NINETY NINE. I WOULD
LIKE TO COMMENT ON A FEW ISSUES
RAISED IN MY MANY MEETINGS WITH
LEGISLATORS. ON THE ISSUE OF
EQUITY. THE STATE AUDITOR
REPORTED IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
BUT MOST OF THE SEVEN TO NINE
THOUSAND OUTSOURCED SERVICE
WORKERS WHO CLEAN THE TOILETS
CUT THE GRASS COOK THE FOOD.
AND TO THE BED PANS. EARN ON
AVERAGE THREE DOLLARS AND
EIGHTY SIX CENTS LESS PER HOUR
THAN UC EMPLOYEES WHO DO THE
SAME WORK. THESE WORKERS ARE
MOSTLY WOMEN OF COLOR WHO DO
NOT HAVE ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE
HEALTH INSURANCE. ON THE ISSUE
OF WORTHINESS OF A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT. LAST
YEAR MOST OF YOU PUT SCA NINE
ON LAST YEAR'S BALLOT. THAT
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT HELPS
HOMEOWNERS INSTALL RAIN WATER
CAPTURE SYSTEMS. AND THEREFORE
THERE IS NOTHING IN NUCLEAR
ABOUT EQUAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY STANDARDS FOR TEN
THOUSAND OUTSOURCED LOW WAGE
CALIFORNIANS IN THAT SAME
CONSTITUTION. ON THE ISSUE OF
FLEXIBILITY. AN AMENDMENT WAS
TAKEN PROTECTING UC'S CURRENT
PER DIEM EMPLOYEE POLICY TO
ALLOW FOR ADEQUATE STAFFING
FLEXIBILITY AT EVERY MEDICAL
CENTER AND ON EVERY CAMPUS. PER
DIEM EMPLOYEES ARE SIMILAR TO
SUBSTITUTE TEACHERS IN OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS. ON THE ISSUE OF
COST. AN ANALYSIS DONE ON THE
ACA BY MIKE GENEST THE DIRECTOR
OF FINANCE FOR THE LAST
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR. SHOWS THAT
WAGE AND BENEFIT PARITY COSTS
FOR THESE SERVICE WORKERS IS
COMPLETELY COMPLETELY OFFSET BY
SAVINGS IN OVERHEAD AND STILL
LEAVES THIRTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS FOR ANY OVERHEAD COSTS
UC MIGHT INCUR. MR GYMNASTS
ANALYSIS IS SUPPORTED BY THE
STATE AUDITOR WHO REPORTED THAT
OUTSOURCED WORKERS MAY COST
MORE THAN YOU SEE EMPLOYEE
WORKERS WHEN YOU ACCOUNT FOR
VENDOR OVERHEAD. ON THE ISSUE
OF THOSE EXISTING OUTSOURCED
CONTRACT. THE ACA APPLIES AT
THE EXPLORATION OR RENEWAL OF
EXISTING CONTRACTS AND SO THIS
MEANS THERE IS A PHASE IN
PERIOD OF UP TO TEN YEARS. AND
THE ACA DOES NOT DICTATE WHO OR
HOW MANY WORKERS SHOULD BE
HIRED. ON THE ISSUE OF WORKING
IT OUT WITH YOU SEE. THE ISSUE
OF OUTSOURCED SERVICE WORKERS
HAS BEEN DISCUSSED FOR OVER A
DECADE. BUT THE ONLY THING THAT
HAS CHANGED IS THE NUMBER OF
OUTSOURCED WORKERS. AND TODAY
THE PERCENTAGE OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS EMPLOYED BY YOU SEE
AS SERVICE WORKERS HAS DECLINED
BY THIRTY PERCENT. WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME 30% OF OUTSOURCED
WORKERS IN LA AND SAN FRANCISCO
ARE NOW AFRICAN AMERICANS. IN
CONCLUSION. UNDER ARTICLE NINE
OF THE CONSTITUTION NEITHER THE
GOVERNOR NOR THE LEGISLATURE
HAVE THE POWER TO ENSURE
SUPPORT SERVICES WORKERS ARE
TREATED EQUALLY. SO I ASK YOU
TO CAN TO EXERCISE YOUR ARTICLE
TWO POWERS AND PLACE ACA
FOURTEEN ON THE BALLOT FOR THE
PEOPLE. WHO ELECTED YOU TO
DECIDE THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS
LIVE ORDER STRAUSS AND. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NELSON ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
HERE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS CRITICAL PIECE OF
LEGISLATION IS STRONG SUPPORT
OF OUR PHILLY WHO'S BRINGING
THIS ISSUE FORWARD AFTER WORK
ATTEMPTING TO WORK OUT AND
FIGHT. FOR THE WORKERS NOT ONLY
IN THEIR BARGAINING UNIT BUT
OUTSIDE OF THEIR BARGAINING
UNIT TO ENSURE THE DISPARITY
OPTING TO THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT WATER RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AND I VOTE FOR THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA TO. WILL
TAKE ONE MORE STEP FORWARD TO
ALLOW THE PEOPLE OF A IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO DECIDE
ON THIS CRITICAL TOPIC. MISTER
ALLISON SIR ARTHUR LIEU HERE
JUST ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. LOW
ALL RIGHT. OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT LET'S LET'S DO THIS I
SEE THAT THERE'S QUITE A NUMBER
OF FOLKS HERE IN AND I KNOW
THAT SOME OF YOU OF TRAVEL
GREAT DISTANCES TO BE HERE SO
IF I COULD JUST ASK ALL THOSE
WHO ARE IN SUPPORT TO STAND OR
RAISE YOUR HAND SO YOU JUST
SORT OF. SEE OKAY. THAT'S THAT
THAT'S QUITE A NUMBER. ALL
RIGHT. THAT THAT'S FINE DO YOU
ARE YOU ALL CAN SIT DOWN NOW
THAT THAT GIVES US SORT OF A
IDEA THE ORDER MAGNITUDE. OF
SUPPORT IN THIS ROOM. SO WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO IS THAT WE'RE
GONNA TAKE SUPPORT FIRST I'M
GONNA TAKE OPPOSITION. SO IF
YOU IF YOU'D LIKE TO LINE UP BY
THE MICROPHONE AND YOU JUST
STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION. THAT WOULD BE
GREAT OR YOUR NAME. AND YOUR
LOCATION OR YOUR WORK LOCATION.
THAT WOULD BE GREAT. BUT WE'VE
SEEN HOW MANY OF YOUR HERE WE
SEEN THAT THE NUMBER OF FOLKS
IN SUPPORT IN THE ROOM. SO YOU
YOU SHOULDN'T FEEL COMPELLED TO
NESTLE COME TO THE MICROPHONE
BUT YOU'RE CERTAINLY WELCOME TO
SO IF I COULD ASK THE THOSE
THAT ARE IN SUPPORT TO LINE UP
TO THE MICROPHONE NOW. THE
MORNING MY NAME IS MAHDI CREWS
MONTHS OF MEDICINE THE SENIOR.
ALL RIGHT MA'AM GO AHEAD YES MY
NAME IS MERRY CHRISTMAS AND NOT
AS AN AMOUNT SENIOR CUSTODIAN
AT UC BERKELEY FOR TWENTY YEARS
AND I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF A CA
FOURTEEN. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
DEANNA CARVAJAL AND I'M AT UC
IRVINE AS AN AUTHORIZATION
COORDINATOR AND I AM IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS PRISCILLA
AUTHORIZED FROM UC IRVINE
MEDICAL CENTER AND IF THE PF AS
THE AS THE MEDICAL COLLECTOR.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS OFFERED A LOCUSTS HAMA AT UC
IRVINE. UC IRVINE MEDICAL
CENTER AUMA PATIENT CARE
TECHNICIAN AND I MEAN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. HI MY NAME IS THE
ELIZABETH RANIL AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT ACA FOURTEEN I'M A
HOUSEKEEPER AND I WORK AT UCI
MEDICAL CENTER THANK YOU. THE
MOVIE IS YOUR I WORK AT UC
IRVINE MEDICAL CENTER I'VE BEEN
THERE FOR YEARS AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT YOU SEE FORTY. Q. HI MY
NAME IS THROUGH TO LEAVE OUR
INPATIENT PHARMACY TECH AT UC
SAN DIEGO I AM IN SUPPORT THE
ACA FOURTEEN. REALLY RESONATED
WITH ESCAPE CALIFORNIA WE
REPRESENT CLASSIFIED RECORDS OF
THE CSU AND SEE IT SIMILAR
PATTERNS SO WE APPLAUD THE OFF
AUTHORS EFFORTS INTO THE
SPONSORED FOR TEAM BRINGS OUR
THING KILL. HI MY NAME IS
DONOVAN ROMAN AND I AM AT THAT
YOU CASF TO BE CANON SITE AND I
AM IN SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS JANET YELLEN'S GUESS I
AM A SEVEN AND A HALF YEAR
EMPLOYEE AT. UCSD HEALTH
SYSTEMS IN I AM IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
BERNADETTE PARKER SENIOR
CUSTODIAN PARNASSUS FACILITY
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF A CA
FOURTEEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS WHAT A LOOP PEDAL LISTEN
FROM UC SAN DIEGO AND NOT A
HOSPITAL SYSTEM THREE AND I'M
IN SUPPORT OF. PCA FOURTEEN.
DALE BEAVERS UC SAN FRANCISCO
LABORATORY TECHNICIAN I SUPPORT
THE CA FOURTEEN. THANK YOU. HI
AM JOANNA FERNANDEZ EMINENT
TOMIC TECHNICIAN AT UCSF FOR
OVER FIVE YEARS AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THE CA FOURTEEN. MY
NAME IS NAOMI NOT CAMARA
PHARMACY TECHNICIAN AT UCSF
MEDICAL CENTER I AM IN SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS ISAAC ZAMORA I'M
FROM UC SAN DIEGO A BEEN THERE
FOR TWELVE YEARS AND I STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ACA FOURTEEN.
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS GLORIA MY
LAW NOVEL I WORKED IN SANTA
MONICA UCLA HI MY GASTROENTEROL
LOGY TECHNICIAN AND I SUPPORT
AC A FOURTEEN. MORNING MY
NAME'S RALPH DAVIS I'M A SENIOR
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT TRAUMA
TECHNICIAN AT THE UC DAVIS
MEDICAL CENTER AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF ACA FOURTEEN. THANK
YOU. I AM CRISTINA SANI I AM AN
X. RAY TECHNOLOGIST I'VE BEEN
WORKING AT UCSF FOR TWELVE
YEARS AND I SUPPORT A C. FORTY.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS JESSICA GREIFF I AM ALSO AN
X. RAY TECHNOLOGIST AT UCSF FOR
OVER TEN YEARS AND I SUPPORT A
C. FOURTEEN. THE MORNING MY
NAME IS LOLITA NOTE. OUR
HOSPITALITY AT UCSF MEDICAL
CENTER AND I'M IN SUPPORT. HI
MY NAME IS VERONICA JONES I'M
IN FROM UCSF SAN FRANCISCO AND
I'M A SUPPORT AC FOURTEEN.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS PRESTON ALAN I'M AN OPTICIAN
AT UC DAVIS AND I SUPPORT A C.
FORTY. JAMIE THE BILL PRESIDENT
OF THE CW A AND ALSO A CASE
MANAGER UC DAVIS WE SUPPORT ACA
FOURTEEN. GOOD MORNING TOM IN
C. VICE PRESIDENT OF UAW TWENTY
SIXTY FIVE ACADEMIC STUDENT
PLAYS YOU SEE IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING ON ALABAMA MEDICAL
ASSISTANT FOR VENICE FAMILY
CLINIC ON OUTSIDE CLINICAL OF
UCLA BEEN THERE FOR FIFTY YEARS
AND I SUPPORT A CA FOURTEEN.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS MONICA MARTINEZ I'M AN
ADMINISTRATIVE CLINICAL CARE
PARTNER FOR THE RUN AROUND YOU
CAN MEDICAL CENTER IN THE
CARDIOTHORACIC UNIT AND I'VE
BEEN THERE EIGHTEEN YEARS AND
I'M IN SUPPORT OF A CA
FOURTEEN. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS MATTHEW
MUSSER I'M A SENIOR LECTURER ON
STUFF LE GRAHAM TECHNOLOGISTS
AT UC DAVIS AND I AM IN SUPPORT
OF A CA FOURTEEN. GOOD MORNING
I'M SANTORUM MERISTEM AN
OPERATING ROOM ASSISTANT AT UC
DAVIS CHILDREN SURGERY AND I AM
IN SUPPORT OF A CA FOURTEEN.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME SONORA I
WORK AT UCLA RONALD REAGAN
EMERGENCY ROOM I'M A
REGISTRATION CLERK AND I
SUPPORT A CA FOURTEEN. THE
MORNING I'M HOLLY KIRK I AM A
SURGICAL TECH AT UC DAVIS HERE
IN SACRAMENTO AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS LYDIA SON I
WORK FOR UC DAVIS MEDICAL
CENTER I'M A UNIT SECRETARY FOR
OVER TWELVE YEARS AND I SUPPORT
ACA FOURTEEN. HI MY NAME IS
STEVE WALKER I'M A SENIOR
AUTOMOTIVE EQUIPMENT OPERATOR
AT U. C. S. C. AS A SHUTTLE BUS
DRIVER AND I AM IN COMPLETE
SUPPORT. FOR A CA FOURTEEN YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS MAYES OF
ELEMENTS STUDENT AT UC IRVINE
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF A CA
FOURTEEN. MY NAME IS MERRY
MORENO CHRISTIAN I'M A STUDENT
AT UC DAVIS AND I AM SUPPORT OF
A C. FOURTEEN. MY NAME IS
JASMINE TOBIN I'M A CERTIFIED
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY ASSISTANT
AT UC MEDICAL CENTER AND I AM
IN SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS A NINE I AM A SENIOR
STUDENT AT UC DAVIS CAMPUS AND
I AM IN SUPPORT. MORNING MY
NAME IS MARIE TOMADA I AM FROM
UCSF. ENSEMBLES PATELLA SYSTEM
THREE AND I SUPPORT A CA
PARKING. HI GOOD MORNING MY
NAME CHAIR GRAY USUALLY AS IF
BY MASSES. I SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS FOR TO
SHOULD TOSHI AND I WORK AT UC
DAVIS MEDICAL CENTER AS A
CENTRAL STERILE TECH AND I
SUPPORT YOU SEE A FOURTEEN.
YEAR. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA TAURUS I WORK AT UC
DAVIS MEDICAL CENTER AT FOR
TWENTY FIVE YEARS I AM A
TRANSPLANT FINANCIAL
COORDINATOR AND I SUPPORT THE
ACA FOURTEEN. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS ANDY CARROLL SAUCE I AM
SENIOR CUSTODIAN AT THE UCLA
CAMPUS. AND I AM IN FULL
SUPPORT OF ACA FORTY. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS JEANETTE
WILL RANGE I AM IN LV AND OUT
OF BURBANK CALIFORNIA AND I AM
IN FULL SUPPORT IF ACA FORTY.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S MOHAMMAD
AKBAR I WORK AT UC DAVIS
MEDICAL CENTER FOR THE PAST
EIGHT YEARS I'M AN OPERATING
ROOM ASSISTANT I'M IN FULL
SUPPORT FOR A CA FOURTEEN.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS JOHN TO FREDDIE NETWORK AT
UC DAVIS MEDICAL CENTER. AND I
AM HIS THE TECHNOLOGIES AND I'M
IN FULL SUPPORT AC FOURTEEN.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS SHOULD
A HUNDRED E. AND I'M A FOURTH
YOUR UC BERKELEY STUDENT AND
I'M IN SUPPORT OF A C. FOURTEEN.
GOOD MORNING HONORABLE TEARING
MEMBERS AMY HEINZ OF THE
UNIVERSITY PROFESSIONAL AND
TECHNICAL EMPLOYEES
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA LOCAL NINETY ONE
NINETEEN IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MORNING MR KERRY MEMBERS MILLIE
BYNUM EDIE W. ASKED ME THIRTY
NINE THIRTY HERE IN FULL
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS AYE SHORES ON MAY I AM IN
THIRD YEAR UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENT AT UC SAN DIEGO AND I
AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF AC
FOURTEEN. THANK YOU. HELLO MY
NAME IS AZRAEL MERA I'M A THIRD
YEAR UNDERGRADUATE AT UC SAN
DIEGO AND I'M IN FULL SUPPORT
OF AC FORTY. HELLO EVERYONE MY
NAME IS ANNA FOR VIETNAM FROM
YOU SEE IS BEING AND I'M HERE
TO SEND SOLIDARITY WITH
INCREDIBLE PEOPLE AND WORKERS
AND I'M HERE TO SPRAY SEE
FOURTEEN. THANK YOU. HELLO GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS YOUR AND
REYES I AM A SECOND YEAR
STUDENT AT UC SANTA BARBARA AND
I'M IN FULL SUPPORT OF AC FORTY.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ALEX
ARE RUN AB I. AM A STUDENT AT
UCSD AND MY DAD'S GROUNDSPEAK A
GROUNDSKEEPER AT UC SAN DIEGO
AND I'M FULL SUPPORT OF A SAY
FOURTEEN. SANDRA BARRERA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION AND THE
UC BERKELEY ALARM IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING NINE NAY JOSE
MEDINA EIGHT WORKING FOR YOU
SEE SAID FOR FOURTEEN YEAR
TENURE GUSTARIA I SUPPORT A CH
FORTY THANK YOU. I'M LUCY
JOSEPH I AM A SENIOR MUSEUM
SCIENTISTS UC DAVIS MEDICAL
TERMINOLOGY DEPARTMENT I'VE
BEEN THERE FOR OVER THIRTY
YEARS MOST OF THE VICE
PRESIDENT FOR UP T. AT THE UC
DAVIS CAMPUS AND I'M HERE IN
FULL SUPPORT. OF ACA FORTY. YOU.
HI MY NAME IS TARA I WORK WITH
UC DAVIS I'M AN LPN AND I'M
FULL SUPPORT OF YOU SEE. AC A
FOURTEEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS SANDRA PENA PAULINO. I Mà
HOSPITAL LABORATORY TECHNICIAN
AT THE UCSF MEDICAL CENTER AND
I AM IN SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS FRANCES GRIP AS
WORKERS UC SAN FRANCISCO. AS
THAT OPPOSES IN THE NATION AND
I SUPPORT ACA FORTY. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS MICHAEL VON
FROM UC SAN DIEGO BEEN THERE
SEVENTEEN AND A HALF YEARS FROM
AS A PATIENT TRANSPORT AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT. ACA FORTY
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS CARLOS BUT I HAS MADE UC
IRVINE SENIOR BILLY MAIN IT'S
FOR TWENTY THREE YEARS NAM IN
SUPPORT OF A CA FOURTEEN. YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS OFTEN
REYES SAMPLES FOR YOUNG AND UC
BERKELEY SO BUT THEY SEE FOR.
BUT MORNING MY NAME IS ALEX
WHAT OCCURS ON WORKING AND UC
BERKELEY ACCOUNTS OF WHAT. YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MATTHEW
SANFORD I WORK AT UC IRVINE
MEDICAL CENTER DOING SELF PAY
COLLECTIONS AND I'M IN FULL
SUPPORT OF A CA FOURTEEN. YEAR.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S RICARDO
MARTINEZ A SENIOR CUSTODIAN I
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS A CELL ROSE FROM FRANCISCO
UC SAN FRANCISCO FOOD AND
NUTRITION I'M IN FULL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING I'M
GLORIA WALLS EMPLOYED UCSF
POLICE DEPARTMENT SECURITY
DIVISION. FOR TWELVE YEARS AND
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF A CA
FORTY. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS CHRISTIAN BRIAN I
WORKED AT UCSF MEDICAL CENTER
MENTION BAY AND ASSETS CAMPUS
PUBLIC SAFETY DIVISION SEEN ON
SECURITY OFFICER AT THE MEDICAL
CENTER A FORTY SUPPORT AC EIGHT
FOURTEEN THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS NORMA
ADVENTIST I WORK AT UC DAVIS
MEDICAL CENTER I'M A PHARMACY
TECHNICIAN FOR TWENTY YEARS AND
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT YOU SEE
FOURTEEN. THE MORNING MY NAME'S
CAROLINE DOYLE I AM A STAFF
RESEARCH ASSOCIATE IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF VITICULTURE AND
ENOLOGY AT UC DAVIS. WITH OVER
THIRTY YEARS OF YOU SEE
EMPLOYMENT HISTORY. AND I'M
ALSO A MEMBER OF MEMBER AND
TRUSTEE OF PROPERTY AND I
SUPPORT. A CA ONE FOURTEEN
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING ON
DAVID SANCIOUS UCSF A TWENTY
SEVEN YEARS TRANSPORTATION
CLOTHES RUBBER AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THEY SEE A FOURTEEN
THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS
JOHN RENDON I'M A LECTURER IN
CLASSICS AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA DAVIS AND I'M WITH
THE UC F. T. WHICH IS THE UNION
THAT REPRESENTS FOUR THOUSAND
LECTURES AND LIBRARIANS AND I
STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF A CA
FOURTEEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS KEVIN RODDY AND LECTURE
EMERITUS AND MEDIEVAL STUDIES
UC DAVIS. AND FORMER PRESIDENT
OF YOU SEE A OF TEEN I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING I'M BILL SOLHEIM A
LECTURER IN THE WRITING PROGRAM
AT UC DAVIS AND A MEMBER OF THE
UC AFT AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT A
CA FOURTEEN. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING I'M KATIE ROGER ON THE
CURRENT LOCAL PRESIDENT OF UCF
TO TWENTY TWENTY THREE AT UC
DAVIS AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT A
CA FOURTEEN. GOOD MORNING BRIAN
HOW WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ANY ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
AS THE ONE MORE PERSON. HELLO
MY NAME IS THE KEY TO CROSS I'M
A STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY AND I
AM INVOLVED WITH THE UNITED
STUDENTS AGAINST SWEATSHOPS AND
I AM SUPPORT AND A C. FOURTEEN.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT OF SAYING
NO ONE ELSE AND WISHES TEST
FIND SUPPORT OPPOSITION BOB
GOOD AS THE OPPOSITION TO COME
FORWARD THINK WE NEED AT LEAST
TWO SEATS HERE AT THE TABLE
.
WE'LL HAVE THE ALLOW THREE IN
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT LIKE TO GO
FIRST GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS JASON MURPHY ON
BEHALF OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HERE TODAY IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO A CA FOURTEEN I
HAVE TWO WITNESSES HERE FROM
OUR CAMPUSES IT ORGAN FOR THAT
SOME TESTIMONY BUT BEFORE THEY
DO SOURCE WILL TAKE A QUICK
MOMENT TO RESPOND TO SOME OF
THECOMMENTS THAT WERE MADE IN
THE IN THE EARLIER
PRESENTATIONS. I SAY IN GENERAL
UNIVERSITY BELIEVES THAT COULD
THE ABILITY TO CONTINUE TO
UTILIZE APPROPRIATE LEVELS OF
CONTRACTING OUT OPPORTUNITIES
AS HAS BEEN ALLOWED IN OUR
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS FOR THE PAST NUMBER
OF YEARS IS STILL APPROPRIATE
AND NECESSARY FOR THE VERSA
CALIFORNIA TO MANAGE THE ONLY
THE HEALTH AFFAIRS THAT OCCUR
ON THE CLINICAL SIDE OF THE
EQUATION BUT ALSO THE GENERAL
CAMPUS. SITUATIONS WE MUST
RESPOND TO AS WELL THESE ARE
SIX SITUATIONS WHERE WE NEED
SPECIALIZED EXPERTISE SHORT
TERM DURATION SPECIALIZED
EQUIPMENT AND SO FORTH OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES WERE TALKING
ABOUT HERE. WITH REGARD TO THE
ISSUE DISPLACEMENT LET ME JUST
MENTION WE DO NOT AGREE WE
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE FRANKLY.
THAT THERE'S BEEN DISPLACEMENT
OCCURRING OF UNIVERSITY
EMPLOYEES THE DATA HAS SHOWN
OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS THAT
WHETHER YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
OVERALL REPRESENTED EMPLOYEE
NUMBERS THOSE NUMBERS HAVE
GROWN APPROXIMATELY. 10% IN THE
LAST FIVE YEARS OR THE
PARTICULAR SERVICE UNITS AND
PATIENT CARE TECHNICAL UNITS
WITHIN THE ASKED ME.
REPRESENTED GROUPS THOSE
NUMBERS HAVE GROWN POSSIBLY 17%
OVER THE PAST FIVE YEARS SO THE
NOTION THAT WERE DISPLACING
PLEASE REPLACE IT WITH
CONTACTED STAFF IS TO SIMPLY
NOT TRUE. REGARDING THE
POTENTIAL USE OF PER DIEM
WORKERS TO SOLVE THE ISSUES
THAT ARE. BROUGHT FORWARD AC
FOURTEEN. I WOULD POINT OUT I
THINK MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE
MEDICAL CENTERS CAN EXPLAIN A
LITTLE BIT MORE DETAIL WE DO
NOT BELIEVE WE AGAIN
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE THAT
PRETTY M. OPPORTUNITIES WILL
SOLVE. EVEN A SMALL PERCENTAGE
OF OUR PROBLEMS AND WE DO NOT
HAVE PRETTY EMPLOYEES ON THE
NON HEALTH NON CLINICAL SITES
SO WE'RE NOT GOING TO DEAL
WITH. CAMPUS ISSUES AT THE
GENERAL CAMPUSES WITH PRETTY
AND ISSUES. WITH REGARD TO THE-
OPINION THAT WAS RENDERED BY MR
GYMNASTS. I WOULD MENTION THAT
WE DID NOT. KNOW OR HEAR ABOUT
THAT OPINION UNTIL JUST
YESTERDAY. I WOULD TELL YOU
THAT MISTER JESTER NOT REACH
OUT TO UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
TO. ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT OUR
FISCAL ESTIMATES AND I'LL TELL
YOU AGAIN THAT WE CONTINUE TO
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE. THAT THE
SAVINGS OR THE FLEXIBILITY THAT
MISTER JEFF BELIEVES IS IN. OUR
SERVICE CONTRACTS OF VOLUMES
ARE GOING TO BE SUFFICIENT TO
COVER THE COSTS OF AC FOURTEEN.
WHAT MR NEST HAS AS UNDERSTAND
EXCEPT AGAIN NOT SEEN THE
ACTUAL DOCUMENT. FAILED TO TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT IS THAT OUR
CONTRACTS INCLUDE A VARIETY OF
THINGS THAT ARE NOT SIMPLY WAGE
BASED. THOSE INCLUDE. EQUIPMENT
TRAINING. SUPPLIES MATERIALS
UNIFORMS INSURANCE. WHOLE
VARIETY OF THINGS THAT GO INTO
THE OVERALL COST OF THE
CONTRACT. THAT ARE NOT JUST
WAGE AND ARE NOT JUST OVERHEAD
OR OR PROFIT FRANKLY TO THE
VENDOR. THOSE ARE THINGS THAT
THE UNIVERSITY WOULD CONTINUE
TO HAVE TO COVER AND PAY FOR IN
ADDITION TO THE EXTRA. WAGE AND
BENEFIT PREMIUMS THAT AC
FOURTEEN WOULD BRING. AND THEN
LASTLY FOR MY COMMENTARIES
MENTION ON THIS QUESTION OF.
THE CONSTITUTION CONSTITUTIONAL
NATURE OF THIS AND WHETHER OR
NOT. A PIECE OF STATUE WOULD BE
SUFFICIENT THE UNIVERSITY WAS
STRONGLY COUNCIL THAT. ACA IS
NOT NECESSARY IN ORDER TO
ACCOMPLISH. THE GOAL THAT THE
AUTHOR HAS PRESENTED HERE. AS
HAS BEEN THE CASE IN THE PAST.
THREE YEARS OF THE- PREVIOUS
LARA BILLS. THOSE BILL SOUGHT
TO. AMENDED THE PUBLIC CONTRACT
CODE. PRETTY CLEAR IN ARTICLE I
SECTION NINE OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION. THAT THE COW FOR
STATE LEGISLATURE CAN PASS
LAWS. THAT GOVERN OUR
COMPETITIVE BIDDING PROCESS
THESE IN PARTICULAR THE
SEES. THE GOVERNMENT ARE
CONTRACTING FOR BUSINESSES FOR
SERVICES AND SO FORTH PRECISELY
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE. SO IF
IT WERE TO BE THE CASE THAT
PIECE OF STATUTE WERE TO COME
FORWARD. THAT WOULD IMPACT
THOSE SAME SERVICES BE
DISCUSSING A CA WE BELIEVE THAT
WOULD BE OPERATIVE IT AND
GOVERN THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA SO. I HOPE TO BE
ABLE TO ANSWER A FEW ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS ON THOSE POINTS LATER
ON AT THIS POINT LIKE TO TURN
OVER TO MY- WITNESSES FOR THEIR
COMMENTS IN ASSAM INTO SOME
CELLS. THANK YOU MISS MURPHY.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I'M
DOCTOR AMY MULLIN I'M AN
EMERGENCY PHYSICIAN AT UC DAVIS
HEALTH AND I'M HERE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF THE ACA. AND
TO TALK ABOUT THE NEGATIVE
IMPACTS THIS BILL WOULD HAVE ON
OUR PATIENTS AND OUR
COMMUNITIES. UC DAVIS IS A
LEVEL ONE TRAUMA CENTER FOR
BOTH PEDIATRICS AND ADULTS AND
WE ARE THE ONLY LEVEL ONE
TRAUMA CENTER ALL THE WAY UP TO
THE OREGON BORDER. AND WHAT
THAT MEANS IS I TAKE CARE OF
THE MOST CRITICALLY INJURED
CHILDREN AND ADULTS FROM MUCH
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. THIS
BILL WOULD IMPACT MY ABILITY TO
PROVIDE THAT CARE. LAST SUNDAY
I WORKED AN OVERNIGHT SHIFT IN
MY EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS. I
HAVE A NINE YEAR OLD BOY WHO
WAS HIT BY A CAR WITH A
BICYCLE. WE WERE EXPERIENCING
DELAYS IN RADIOLOGY. IT TOOK
OVER THREE HOURS FOR US TO GET
A C. T. SCAN ON THIS CRITICALLY
INJURED CHILD. THAT WAS A DELAY
IN HIS CARE. BUT ALSO DELAY IN
MY ABILITY TO TAKE CARE OF
PATIENTS IN THE WAITING ROOM
AND TO GET HIM UPSTAIRS TO THE
TRAUMA SURGERY DEPARTMENT. THAT
NIGHT THEY WERE FIVE CHILDREN
IN MY WAITING ROOM THAT I COULD
NOT GET TO YOU. SO THE RIPPLE
EFFECTS OF NOT HAVING ADEQUATE
STAFFING IN OUR TRAUMA CENTERS
HAVE LONG RANGING RIPPLE
EFFECTS DELAYS IN LAB DELAYS IN
CT SCAN IN RADIOLOGY. RIPPLE
DOWN INTO THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT TO PATIENTS ACROSS.
CALIFORNIA BUT THEN CAUSE
DELAYS IN OUR ABILITY TO TAKE
AMBULANCE TRAFFIC WHICH AFFECTS
NEIGHBORING HOSPITALS. CONTRACT
WORKERS ARE NEEDED IN A VARIETY
OF SITUATIONS TO FILL IN GAPS.
WE NEED JANITORIAL STAFF TO
TURN OVER BEDS IN ORDER TO GET
PATIENTS OUT OF THE WAITING
ROOM. HOSPITAL CAN THOSE DELAYS
CAN LEAD TO. AMBULANCE DELAYS
IT'S ALL CONNECTED AND IT
IMPACTS OUR COMMUNITIES WE
EXPERIENCE THESE SURGES EVERY
YEAR SO EVERY YEAR I WATCH. THE
FLU SEASON MARCH ACROSS THE
COUNTRY I DON'T KNOW WHEN IT'S
GOING TO START. AND I DON'T
KNOW HOW HOW BAD IT'S GOING TO
BE BUT WE KNOW EVERY YEAR
DURING FLU SEASON WE WILL
EXPERIENCE SEARCHES. DURING
THESE TIMES IT'S NOT JUST MY
HOSPITAL THAT EXPERIENCES
SURGES EVERY HOSPITAL
EXPERIENCES THE SEARCHES AND
WE'RE ALL STRAPPED. DURING
THOSE TIMES IT IS ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE TO GET PER DIEM
STAFF BECAUSE THEY'RE NEEDED AT
OTHER HOSPITALS AS WELL. THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
HOSPITALS ARE THE BACKBONEOF
THE SAFETY NET IN CALIFORNIA
THESE ARE YOUR TRAUMA CENTERS
THESE ARE YOUR STROKES CENTERS
THESE ARE YOUR HEART ATTACKS
CENTERS. UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS HAVE LESS
THAN 6% OF THE BEDS IN
CALIFORNIA BUT PROVIDE THE
SECOND LARGEST CARE FOR
INPATIENT AND OUTPATIENT CARE
FOR OUR MEDI CAL POPULATION.
ECA WOULD AC FOURTEEN WOULD
DIRECTLY IMPACT OUR HOSPITAL
SYSTEMS ARE PATIENTS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR MULLIN SIR. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS JOE
FARRELL AND THE CHIEF OF POLICE
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
DAVIS. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK HERE THIS
MORNING IF THE PRIVILEGE AND I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THIS
BILLS IMPORTANT TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE. THIS MORNING I
REPRESENT NOT ONLY MYSELF BUT
THE OTHER NINE CHEESE OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. WHO
SERVE OUR CAMPUSES AND OUR OUR
MED CENTER. IF YOU DEBATE THIS
THIS PUBLIC POLICY WOULD JUST
ASK YOU TO CONSIDER. WHAT WE
BELIEVE MAY BE SOME ON THE TAG
IMPACT OR DAY TO DAY OPERATIONS
OF THIS PROPOSAL. THERE ARE A
VARIETY OF SITUATIONS WHERE THE
UNIVERSITY SPECIFICALLY ON THE
ACADEMIC CAMPUSES MUST
OUTSOURCING CONTRACT SHORT TERM
ASSIGNMENTS THAT ARE NOT NEEDED
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE YEAR. I
MEAN EVERY EVERY CAMPUSES
DEPEND UPON OUR ABILITY TO
AUGMENT OUR EXISTING STAFF FOR
SPECIAL EVENTS. WE HAVE NEVER
DISPLACED ANY OF OUR EXISTING
STAFF WE MERRILY MERGE THEM IN
WITH OUR SEARCH STAFFING TO BE
ABLE TO PROPERLY SECURE EVENTS
THAT COME ON DOOR CAMPUSES.
ALSO TO THAT WE WERE VERY VERY
DEPENDENT UPON TECHNOLOGY WE
EMPLOY A LOT OF CAMBER SYSTEMS
KEY CARD ACCESS BIRDS YOU CALL
BOXES. ALL THE EQUIPMENT.
UPDATE AND MAINTAIN BOTH
SERVICES THROUGHOUT THE YEAR.
OR COLLEGIATE SPORTS OR SPECIAL
EVENTS ARE ESPECIALLY AT THE
LARGER CAMPUSES THE UCLA'S IN
THE IN THE BARCLAYS DAVIS IS
SAME WAY. WE WERE EXTREMELY
DEPENDENT ALL ON OUR ABILITY TO
HIRE OUTSOURCING SECURITY TO BE
ABLE TO DO OUR JOBS TO SECURE
THOSE THOSE EVENTS. WE'VE TRIED
IN THE PAST TO DO SOME OF THESE
JOBS WITHOUT CONTRACTING OUT.
IT'S A LARGE HUGE ALMOST
INSURMOUNTABLE DEMAND ON
EXISTING STAFF WE HAVE TO
MANDATE OVERTIME. WE HAVE TO
CALL PEOPLE IN WE HAVE TO
REDUCE VACATIONS AND DAYS OFF
TO BE OF THE DO THESE EVENTS
ONLY BE COMPLICATED WHEN THE
EVENTS FOR OVER WE HAVE VERY
MINIMAL STAFF BECAUSE WE'VE
USED THEM FULL CAPACITY FOR THE
FEW DAYS OF THESE THESE LARGER
EVENTS. AT THE VERY END OKAY MY
COMES VERY VERY SHORT. WE ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE OVERALL
SECURITY OF THESE CAMPUSES. AND
WE BELIEVE THAT THERE MAY BE
SOME UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
THAT IF WERE PROHIBITED OR
REDUCED ON OUR ABILITY TO
CONTRACT OUT SPECIAL SECURITY
STAFF FOR SPECIAL HIGH PROFILE
EVENTS. I DON'T THINK THIS WHAT
WAS INTENDED OF THIS
LEGISLATION WE JUST ASK THAT
YOU CONSIDER THAT AS YOU MAKE A
DECISION. THANK YOU. OTHERS.
MORNING SUN HENSCHEL HERE ON
BEHALF OF AMERICAN MEDICAL
RESPONSE RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. FRED MADE
ON BEHALF OF THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE ALLIANCE VENTURE IN
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY YOU SEE IS
A SANTA BARBARA IS AN IMPORTANT
PART OF THE- ECONOMY THE
CENTRAL COAST REGION WERE
OPPOSED. BARBARA GLAZER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL IS SO
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING BOTH
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE HOSPITALS IN
OPPOSITION. KELLY BROOKS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC HOSPITALS
AND HEALTH SYSTEMS WE JUST KNOW
THAT THESE CONTRACTING OUT
PROVISIONS WOULD ONLY APPLY TO
THE FIVE YOU SEE HOSPITALS ARE
NOT TO THE OTHER FOUR HUNDRED
HOSPITALS IN THE STATE. THANK
YOU. HOWARD WOLINSKY THE OF
CALIFORNIA. COALITION OF PUBLIC
HIGHER EDUCATION IN OPPOSITION.
THE QUESTION ONLY RIGHT.
CIRCUMSTANCE WITH A NINE YEAR
OLD BOY WORRY THERE WAS A THREE
HOUR WAIT BEFORE YOU COULD GET
A CT SCAN. HOW WOULD A CA
FOURTEEN AFFECT YOUR ABILITY TO.
LOOKS. THAT NIGHT WE HAD A
BACKUP IN RADIOLOGY WE HAD
STAFF WHO WANT TO DID NOT COME
IN THAT NIGHT TO WORK IN THE
RADIOLOGY DEPARTMENT IN A CA
FOURTEEN WOULD DECREASE OUR
ABILITY TO INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF EMPLOYEES ON SURGES LIKE
THAT TO COVER THE RADIOLOGY
DEPARTMENT. IT SOUNDS LIKE
THERE'S ALREADY AN ISSUE SO
OKAY. I APPRECIATE THE
ENTHUSIASM THAT WASN'T MEANT TO
BE AN APPLAUSE LINE YEAH SO
HERE SO HERE RIGHT HERE IS. WE
OPERATE BARELY ABOVE WATER.
EVERY DAY SO I WILL SAY YES IT
IS HARD EVERY DAY TO PROVIDE
CARE THAT IS NEEDED TO OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND SO ANYTHING
THAT IS DONE THAT DECREASES OUR
ABILITY TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
OUR PATIENTS AND OUR
COMMUNITIES IS GONNA BE A NET
NEGATIVE. BECAUSE WE'RE BARELY
KEEPING UP WITH THE DEMAND
CURRENTLY THAT IS MY CONCERN
RIGHT. IN OF THIS IS TO
ASSEMBLY WOMAN CONSEILS WE
PROPOSE I REALIZE WE'RE NOT
GONNA TAKE ANY MEMBERS HERE
YOU'RE NOT GONNA TAKE ANY
MEMBERS HERE BUT FOR
APPROPRIATIONS WANT ONE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT I'VE RAISED IT IS
JUST THAT FLEXIBILITY WITHIN.
THE UC MED CENTERS AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT YOU AGREE
TO TAKE. AN AMENDMENT THAT
PROVIDES FOR SORT OF AN
EXPANDED DEFINITION OF WHEN
EMERGENCY CIRCUMSTANCES MAY
OCCUR IS THAT RIGHT YES SO THE
ABSOLUTELY SO WE'LL TAKE THAT
APPROPRIATIONS. NOW SECTION
NINE POINT FIVE CAPITAL A- WILL
WILL READ A BONA FIDE EMERGENCY
CIRCUMSTANCE WHICH MAY INCLUDE
BUT IS NOT LIMITED TO IS THAT
CORRECT. ALL RIGHT. OTHER
QUESTIONS MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THE SENATE IS THERE
LOW. FAIR I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD OR THIS ACA ARE HAPPY
TO BE A CO AUTHOR AND I THINK
WE KIND OF SEE A THEME WITH
EVERYONE WHO TESTIFIED THIS IS
OUR SUPPORT STAFF THESE ARE THE
PEOPLE WHO MAKE SURE THAT THE
UC CAMPUSES RUN WITHOUT ALL OF
YOU WITHOUT ALL OF THE
THOUSANDS MORE THAT ARE HERE.
THESE CAMPUSES DON'T RUN AND
THEY ARE OPEN TO OUR STUDENTS
AND FUTURE LEADERS I THINK THE
OTHER THING WE SEE IS WHAT ARE
WE TELLING STUDENTS AT UC WHEN
WE SEE THAT SUPPORT STAFF IS
TREATED DIFFERENTLY ARE WE
TEACHING THEM THAT THERE IS A
SECOND CLASS OF CITIZENS AND
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE SHOULD BE
DOING SO I FULLY SUPPORT THIS I
FULLY SUPPORT ALL OF YOU. I
KNOW THAT YOU ARE ALL VALUABLE
AND WITHOUT YOUTHE UC'S DON'T
OPERATE WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE STUDENTS THAT WERE
EDUCATING KNOW THAT EVERY JOB
IS VALUABLE BUT ALL WORK IS
VALUED THAT IF EVERYONE THERE
IS NOT VALUED WE'RE DOING
SOMETHING WRONG IN SOCIETY
WE'RE MAKING THEM FEEL LIKE
THEY ARE LESS THAN AND THAT'S
ON ALL OF US SO SHAME ON US IF
WE CAN'T FIX FIX THIS. ITEM. IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU HERTZBERG THANK
YOU INSTRUMENT THAN EVERYBODY
FOR SHOWING UP FROM ALL
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE STATE
IT'S VERY IMPRESSIVE A SHOWING
AND OF THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
ISSUE I'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN
THIS FOR MORE THAN TWENTY YEARS
I SERVED ON THE BOARD OF
REGENTS MANY YEARS AGO AND HAVE
LIVED THROUGH THE HISTORY OF
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES BETWEEN
LABOR ON THE ONE HAND. AND THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA IN THE
OTHER MR PELOTA TERMS OF HIS
LEADERSHIP. IN THE EARLIER DAYS
IN THE LIKE AND SAW. A THAT
THIS WHERE WE ARE TODAY IS NOT
AS IT IS ISOLATION IT IS A
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE THAT. AT
THE UNIVERSITY AND HOW WHICH
NEGOTIATORS OF TREATED FOLKS
HAS NOT BEEN GOOD THEY HAVEN'T
BEEN TRANSPARENT. AND I DON'T
THINK WE'D BE HERE TODAY IF WE
DIDN'T HAVE THAT HISTORY. AND
SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT AS WE
LOOK TODAY TO THE ISSUES THAT
WE FACE IS TO UNDERSTAND THAT
HISTORY. ARMED AND UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE'S A REASONABLE BASIS
OF FRUSTRATION THAT HAS
OCCURRED IN TERMS OF THOSE
NEGOTIATIONS AND LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY IN THE LIKE IT'S A
BIG DEAL. THAT BEING SAID. ARE
YOU KNOW THE QUESTION IS AND I
ALSO REMEMBER WHEN DON PRADA
DISPATCH JOHN BURTON THE FORMER
PRO TEM OF THIS HOUSE. TO TRY
TO ENGAGE IN THOSE NEGOTIATIONS
YOU WALK BACK IN FRUSTRATION
I'VE SEEN ALL THIS STUFF OVER
THE YEARS. AND WATCHED WHAT
HAPPENED THE QUESTION IS BEFORE
US TODAY IS. DOES THIS RISE TO
THE LEVEL OF A CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT DO YOU NEED TO CHANGE
THE CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE THE LEVEL OF PROTECTION
SWITCH CENTER LABOR.
APPROPRIATELY REFERRED TO
THAT'S THE QUESTION BEFORE US
CERTAINLY I AM SOMEWHAT
PERSUADED I CERTAINLY AND I
KNOW BUT IT'S NOT A REAL HONEST
ANSWER BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN THERE
BEFOREWAS CENTER LARA. WITH
RESPECT ARTICLE NINE SECTION
NINE RESPECT ALL THE VARIOUS
PROVISIONS WHICH I PULLED OUT
AND READ OF THE PUBLIC
CONTRACTING CODE. THAT ARE NOW
REQUIRED DO YOU NEED THIS IN
THE CONSTITUTION WHAT IS THE
BALLOT CAN LOOK LIKE IF THIS IS
ON THERE WITH ALL THE OTHER
THINGS THAT WE KNOW WE'RE GOING
TO BE ON THE BALLOT. HOW DOES
THAT WORK OUT IN ORDER TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN. MY MESSAGE TODAY
I'M GOING TO VOTE FOR THIS
TODAY BUT I'M VOTING WITH A
VERY STRONG AT THE NATION. GET
TO THE TABLE YOU HAVE THE BEST.
OF CHAIR OF THE BOARD OF
REGENTS THAT WE'VE EVER HAD
WITH RESPECT TO LABOR
NEGOTIATIONS BECAME A LABOR
MOVE HE WAS SPEAKER. OF THE FOR
STATE BLAKE AND I BELIEVE THEY
A THAT HE WILL STEP DOWN AT THE
TABLE WITH YOU AND NOT. AND
NOT. ENGAGE IN THE KIND OF
CHALLENGE THAT WE SAW BEFORE
WHERE THE PEOPLE WERE
NEGOTIATED IF YOU. HAD BUT WE
SEEN FOR THE LAST TWO DECADES
WHICH INFORMS THIS FRUSTRATION
OF WHY YOU FEEL YOU NEED. HEY
THAT YOU NEED A RIDE HELLO A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT
BECAUSE SITUATION IS SO BAD.
BUT AS THE ABILITY OF HAD TO
THAT MONEY. MORE PRESSURE AT
SOME LEVEL BUT I ALSO THINK IT
REQUIRES. ALL EVERYBODY TO BE
SET AT THE TABLE I DON'T NOT
WANT TO SIT AND SAY NOBODY'S TO
THE TABLE TO LAUGHTER SESSIONS
CLOSED. OUT IN SEPTEMBER
THIRTEENTH I DON'T THINK THAT'S
RIGHT. PERIOD AND I THINK IT'S
BEEN FUNDAMENTALLY WRONG.
EVERYBODY NEEDS TO BE USED
EVERY BEST EFFORT TO TRY TO GET
TO THE TABLE THE CD COULD REACH
A RESOLUTION ON THIS STUFF. I
KNOW THE ARGUMENT HAS BEEN MADE
THAT WELL OKAY. GREAT WE HAVE
MISTER PRESIDENT CHAIR AND
THAT'LL BE LIMITED CONTRACT
DOESN'T PROTECT EVERYBODY GOING
FORWARD. OUR ARGUMENT OKAY. BUT
I THINK CREATIVE LAWYERS CAN
WRITE ALL KINDS OF PROVISIONS
IN YOUR- NEGOTIATING DOCUMENTS
AND I THINK THAT. IT'S QUITE
IMPORTANT THAT EVERYBODY SITS
TO THE TABLE I WILL. VOTE FOR
IT IN ORDER TO KEEP THE PROCESS
MOVING HOPEFULLY GETS OUT OF
APPROPRIATIONS WE CAN. TAKE IT
TO THE FLOOR BUT MY AT MY VERY
HOPE IS THAT I WILL NOT COMMIT
TO VOTE FOR. FLOOR AND I HOPE
THAT. ALL OF THIS THING IS
RESOLVED BEFORE THAT TIME. SO
THAT THE ISSUES THAT WE CARE
ABOUT OUR TAKEN CARE OF. AND
THIS DOES NOT HAVE TO GO ON THE
BALLOT IN THE FORM OF A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT. THAT
IMPACTS SO MANY OTHER ELEMENTS
OF OTHER CRITICAL ISSUES THAT
WE FACE ON THE TAX CODE ON. ALL
SORTS OF ISSUES THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DEAL WITH. AND TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE SO. I DO THINK IT BEARS
SOME HOMEWORK BUT I ALL I CAN
SAY IS. YOU KNOW I DOING IT
WITH THE- COULD. BE THOUGHT
BANDING AND HOPE THAT EVERYBODY
WILL. COME TO THE TABLE. AND
THAT THE IT'S CLEAR TO ME FOR
COMMUNICATION UNIVERSITY. WITH
MISTER PERES THE TABLE. IT WILL
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE AND THE
KINDS OF. VERY DIFFICULT
CHALLENGE THAT YOU HAVE I HAVE
SEEN. FOR THE LAST TWENTY YEARS
IT WON'T HAPPEN. THIS TIME
ROUND. STERN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND THANK YOU TO ALL THE-
WORKING PEOPLE SHOWED UP TODAY
AS WELL AS TO. THE AUTHOR FOR.
STAND UP FOR PEOPLE TIME AFTER
TIME WHO OFTEN DON'T HAVE A
VOICE YEAH I WAS I WAS A CALLA.
TWO THOUSAND NINE SORRY GOING
TO LAW SCHOOL I KNOW. THE
SOUTHERNERS THOUGH SHE STANFORD.
AGAIN WELL AND I HAVE YOU KNOW
THIS FIRST YEAR LAW SCHOOL
YEARS SIR TO GET YOUR HEAD DOWN
IN THE BOOKS. STRESSING OUT
DOING YOUR THING. BUT I
REMEMBER THESE PEOPLE IN GREEN
SHOWED UP AT THE TOP OF THE
HILL RIGHT AT THE TOP OF
BANKRUPT THE UNIVERSITY HALL
WE'RE ALL STANDING THERE AND I.
DON'T HAVE THIS HAPPEN ACTUALLY
HARVARD WHEN I WAS A FRESHMAN
THERE SAME THINGS THE TENT CITY
IMMERSION FRONT OF MY DORM ROOM
AND- HE'S IN THERE WITH ALL
THIS PRIVILEGE. INCREDIBLE
EDUCATION. AND THEN YOU YOU
WONDER HOW YOUR DORM ROOM THAT
CLEANED UP OR WHY THE CAMPUS IS
SAFE OR WHY. YOU KNOW YOU CAN
GO ABOUT YOUR LIFE WITH YOUR
HEAD IN YOUR BOOKS AND YOU
REALIZE YOU'RE NOT SEPARATE IS
A STUDENT AND YOU'RE NOT ABOVE
PEOPLE. AND SO I STOOD ON THE
PICKET LINES. AND IT'S AN
INTERESTING POSITION TO BE
SITTING HERE TODAY NOW TRYING
TO PUT THAT LEGAL EDUCATION TO
WORK TO TRY TO. RESULT THE SAME
PROBLEM WE'VE BEEN HAVING FOR.
DECADES IT'S VERY FRUSTRATING
FRANKLY THEY HAVE TO BE AT THIS
MOMENT. I SHARE SOME OF THE
FRUSTRATION OF HEARD FROM MY
COLLEAGUE FOR SAN FERNANDO TO
IT'S LIKE. ALL THESE FAILED
ATTEMPTS OVER THESE PAST FEW
YEARS AND ALL THE. THREE
IMPASSESREACH THAT WE NOW HAVE
TO FORCE IT TO THIS LEVEL BUT.
M. IF YOU IF YOU DIDN'T TOLD ME
CAN WE- USING THAT SORT OF
WONKY YOUR SIDE HELP US THROUGH.
JUST MECHANICALLY WHY THIS
ROUTE WHY WE'VE GOT TO GO WHAT.
WHAT IS A CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT TO THAT THAT LARA
BILL DIDN'T DO OR WHETHER WEBER
BILL SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT BUT.
WIDE START LET'S LET'S JUST
START THERE WHAT WHY WHAT WHAT
CAN WE DO THROUGH EITHER AT THE
TABLE OR IN STATUTES THAT THAT
NEED THAT MAKES THIS THE RIGHT
MECHANICS TO GETTING THAT EQUAL
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY I GUESS
I'D I'D START WITH. YOU AUTHOR
MS LIVE ORDER AND THEN. MAYBE A
LITTLE I DO WANNA GET ABOUT A
GYMNAST LETTER TO I WANT TO
AGITATE ON THAT THOSE THE TWO
ISSUES I WAS HOPING WE COULD
SORT OF. LOOK AT. SO. THE
PREFERENCE HERE I'M GONNA HAVE
MISLED BIGELOW AT STANFORD LAW
EDUCATION. WITH AN UNDERGRAD I
ACTUALLY UCLA LOSS OKAY I DON'T
WANT IT. YES I DO IS JUST THE
DIRECT. I BELIEVE THAT YOU WERE
AT CAL THAT MAKE ME FEEL BAD
FOR YOU SO I'M SORRY THAT'S
RIGHT. AND GO BEARS. THERE'S SO
SENATOR I APPRECIATE THE
CONCERNS THAT YOU'VE RAISED AND-
YOU KNOW. ONE FUNDAMENTAL
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE ACA AND
THE LAR BILL IS THAT THE ACA
ACTUALLY ADDRESSES THE PUBLIC
INSTITUTION DIRECTLY AND THE
CONCERN THERE. THE LARA BILLS.
BY LAW COULD ONLY REGULATE THE
ENTITIES THAT DID BUSINESS WITH
THE PUBLIC INSTITUTION. BUT I
THINK MORE FUNDAMENTALLY IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT NO ONE CONFLATES
PUBLIC POLICY WITH COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING ON ISSUES AS
FUNDAMENTAL AS EQUAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY. IN CALIFORNIA WE
DON'T RELEGATE ISSUES OF A
QUALITY TO THE VAGARIES OF
NEGOTIATIONS AMONG ANY TWO
PARTIES. WHETHER IT'S VOTING
RIGHTS GENDER PAY EQUITY OR
MARRIAGE EQUALITY. ACA FOURTEEN
IS PUBLIC POLICY FOR A PUBLIC
INSTITUTION. BUT VOTERS SHOULD
HAVE A CHANCE TO ENSHRINE IN
THE STATE CONSTITUTION. THERE'S
AN ANSWER QUESTIONS. I THE
MECHANICS I GET YOUR YOU'RE
GOING AFTER THE PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS SOME MATTERS OF
PRINCIPLE ARE NOT NEGOTIABLE I
GET THAT SORT OF POLICY
PRINCIPLE. BUT. COULD COULD WE
ACTUALLY ACHIEVE THAT I GUESS
THE WAY THE IF I UNDERSTAND THE
WAY THIS IS WRITTEN WE STILL
HAVE ROOM FOR SOME STATURE
THEIR STATUTORY ROOM PRESERVED
HERE AND IN FACT IT WOULD SORT
OF COMPELLED THE LEGISLATURE TO
ADDRESS. THIS IS THE CONTRACT
WORK STATUTORILY GOING FORWARD
THAT SORT OF THE INVERSE I
GUESS OF WHAT. THE LARA MODEL
WOULD HAVE BEEN WHICH IS
STATUTES FIRST AND THEN PUSH IT
BACK BUT- IS YOUR SENSE THAT.
SOME OF THE ISSUES RAISED BY
THE OPPOSITION AND CONCERNS
FROM THE UC COULD WE DEAL WITH
THAT BY STATUTE FOR SAY THOSE
EXTRA ASSISTANCE IN THE
RADIOLOGY UNIT OR THE SPECIAL
EVENTS CIRCUMSTANCE THAT AT
PUBLIC SAFETY PERSONNEL POINTED
OUT. IN SORT OF SUBSEQUENT
STATUTE I'M READING IN. C. ONE
A UNDER THIS SORT OF NOT ARE
NOT JUST A BUT SORT OF ALL THE
PERMISSIVE. EMERGENT BONAFIDE
EMERGENCY CIRCUMSTANCES MEANS
THAT THESE OTHERS WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS THAT STATUTORILY BUT
COULD WE COULD BUT THERE IS
PLENTY AYE AYE THINKING WE'VE
JUST ADDED TO THOSE EXEMPTIONS
THAT WERE WERE ALLOWING FOR
EMERGENCIES NOW ESPECIALLY WITH
THE MEDICAL CENTER. SO YES IF
THERE IS OVER REGENE IDEAS THAT
THAT COME UP YOU KNOW WE DON'T
KNOW HOW WHAT CIRCUMSTANCES
CHANGE OVER TIME WE COULD. BED
TO GO BACK YOU KNOW AND HAVING
WORKED WITH. CENTER LARA ON
THAT BILL AS. THERE ARE TWO
THINGS I WOULD SAY. ONE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT EQUAL OPPORTUNITY.
RIGHT I CAN THINK OF NOTHING
MORE FUNDAMENTAL THAT BELONGS
IN. THE CONSTITUTION. THEN THEN
THE RIGHT TO BE TREATED EQUALLY
AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT WE'RE
GETTING AT HERE AND WHEN YOU
COMBINE THAT WITH WHAT WE KNOW
HAS HAPPENED SPECIFICALLY
AFRICAN AMERICAN WORKERS AT THE
UC. I DON'T WANT TO LEAVE IT UP
TO CREATE OF LAWYERS I'D RATHER
TRUST THE VOTERS IN THE STATE
TO MAKE A DECISION ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT WE WANT. YOU
KNOW ARE VERY. LARGE EMPLOYER
PUBLIC INSTITUTION TO STAND BY
CERTAIN IDEALS SO SOMETIMES WE
IN TRYING THINGS IN THE
CONSTITUTION BECAUSE WE BELIEVE
SO DEEPLY AND THOSE PRINCIPLES.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE AND I'VE SEEN THINGS
GET PUT INTO THE CONSTITUTION I
DO BELIEVE THAT DEEPLY ON RAIN
WATER CAPTURE. I JACKIE THE
BILL BUT YOU NOW WE GOT IT IN
THE CONSTITUTION. THAT WAS A
TAX EXILE IT WAS A PLEASURE
BILL YOU KNOW IN AND THAT'S
OKAY BECAUSE WE HAD TO DO IT
THAT WAY YOU KNOW I DON'T
BELIEVE IT IT'S NOT MY CORE
FUNCTION THE OF THE RIGHT TO
FISH BUT THAT'S IN OUR
CONSTITUTION. IT IS IN MY COURT
IF. INDIVIDUALS ESPECIALLY BY
OUR PUBLIC UNIVERSITY SHOULD BE
TREATED EQUALLY. AND I THINK
THAT BELONGS IN THE
CONSTITUTION NOT BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS WITH CREATIVE LAWYERING
AND SO I THINK WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WHAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE NOW LET'S SET THAT
ASIDE THAT'S- YOU KNOW. MY
PERSONAL BELIEF I THINK ALL OF
OUR BELIEFS TO BE HONEST IT'S
WET REPLIES. DO YOU SEE WAS
RIGHT ON THE LARA BELL. THE
LUCY WAS RIGHT AND COST MORE
MONEY. BECAUSE THE WAY WE HAD
TO DO THE BUILD CONTRACTORS
WOULD JUST RAISE THE PRICE OF
THE CONTRACT. WHAT WE KNOW NOW
AND WHAT WE KNOW INTUITIVELY
BUT WE ACTUALLY NOW IS. THE ACA
WON'T COST MORE MONEY I WOULD
ASK THE UC FOR EVERY DOLLAR
THEY PAID FOR A CONTRACT WORKER
SALARY HOW MUCH DO THEY PAY FOR
OVERHEAD FOR THAT CONTRACTOR. I
GUESS IT'S AROUND SIXTY SIX
CENTS FOR EVERY DOLLAR I COULD
BE WRONG THEY CAN CORRECT ME
BUT I THINK IT'S WELL. I'M SURE
WE CAN. FIGURE THAT OUT. BUT
I'D SAY IT'S SIXTY SIXTY SIX
CENTS I'M JUST GUESSING. WE
IT'S NOT WE CAN SLOWLY
ESPECIALLY OVER TIME THESE
CONTRACTS BRING THAT IN IT HE
FOR THE INCREASE IN ACTUAL
PEOPLE'S SALARIES AND BENEFITS
BEING TREATED EQUALLY. SO I
CAN'T IMAGINE NOW HAVING
ALREADY YOU KNOW I SUPPORTED
LARS BILL AGAIN I JACQUI THAT
WHEN AND BELIEVED IN IT BUT
THIS IS ACTUALLY A PREFERRED
BULL. METHOD OF GOING BY
CREATING EQUAL OPPORTUNITY. ALL
BECAUSE NUMBER ONE IT DOESN'T
SHINE IT A PRINCIPLE I THINK WE
ALL BELIEVE IN AND NUMBER TWO I
THINK THE COSTS MAKE MORE SENSE.
AT THE CHAIR APPROPRIATIONS IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND SOMETHING I
CARE DEEPLY ABOUT. SO LET'S TRY
FLIP IT BACK TO. YOU SEE A C.
SHAKING YOUR HEAD THERE'S A LOT
THE LINE SAYS IN IN THE GYMNAST
LETTER THAT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REFERRED TO UNLESS AND UNTIL
YOU SEE CAN PROVIDE ITEMIZE
JUSTIFICATION OF ITS NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL OVERHEAD FUNDING WE
CONCLUDE THAT IT CAN ABSORB THE
COST OF A C. FOURTEEN. WITHIN
THE AMOUNTS CURRENTLY BUDGETED
FOR THESE EXISTING CONTRACTS.
WHAT WHAT IS THE MATH IF NOT
THAT HOW DO YOU DO YOU REALLY
SEE IT AS A YOU SEE IT AS MORE
THAN THIRTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL EXPENSES
AS OUTLINED. YES THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION CENTER STERN WE DO
BELIEVE IS BORN I SPOKE TO THIS
A LITTLE BIT IN MY- DIRECTORY
COMMENTS NOTING THAT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE TOTALITY OF A
SERVICE CONTRACT WHETHER IT BE
FOR CUSTODIAL OR- BUILDINGS AND
GROUNDS ARE FOOD SERVICE OR
WHAT HAVE YOU. THERE'S A
VARIETY OF THINGS THAT GO INTO
THAT WE'VE BEEN ACKNOWLEDGING
THE FOR THE LAST FIVE YEARS AS
A FUNCTION OF OUR EFFORTS ON
PREVIOUS LARA BILLS AND
PREVIOUS WEBER BILLS AND BY THE
WAY. I'D BE HAPPY TO GO BACK
AND SORT THROUGH AND WORK
THROUGH THOSE FISCAL EXPENSE OF
ANYBODY WHO WOULD BE WILLING TO
SHOW THAT WE'VE DONE THE SAME
METHODOLOGY FOR FIVE YEARS IT'S
BEEN CONTINUALLY SAME. WE'VE
DONE THAT FOR THE PURPOSES OF
BEING DEFENSIBLE AND BEING
CLEAR AND BEING ABLE TO SHOW
THE SIMILAR APPROACH FROM YEAR
TO YEAR. SO WHAT WE WHAT WE
TAKE ISSUE WITH THE CHEN S.
METHODOLOGY TO GET WE JUST. BUT
WHERE THIS FOR THE LAST TWENTY
FOUR HOURS IS THAT. IT FAILS TO
RECOGNIZE THERE ARE THINGS
OTHER THAN. THE WAGE COMPONENTS
AND OUT INTO THE EQUIPMENT
TRAINING SUPPLIES SO WHAT TO
WHAT YOU IN YOUR MIND LIKE GIVE
US A GUESSTIMATE GIVES US
RIGHT. WE WERE TO MEET THIS GAP
BECAUSE IF WE DON'T WANT TO PUT
THAT NINE YEAR OLD BOY A WRIST
BUT WE ALSO. DON'T THINK THAT
TAKING CARE THE NINE YOUR BOY.
IS MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE TO TAKING
CARE OF. THOUSANDS OF WORKERS
LIKE IT'S RIGHT LIKE WE CAN DO
BOTH RIGHT BECAUSE THAT. THAT'S
THE GOAL RIGHT IS TAKE CARE OF.
ALL THE WHOLE SYSTEM MAKE IT
HEALTHY WHAT'S THE GAS WHAT
WHAT ARE WE LOOKING. WELL THE
GAP IS A HUNDRED SEVEN TWO
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS WHICH
IS THE FISCAL WE PUT FORWARD ON
THIS BILL. GOING BACK TO THE
SOME THE WOMAN STATEMENT ABOUT.
THE PERCENTAGE OF THE
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATED WITH
OVERHEAD OR OR WHATEVER YOU
WANNA CALL PROFITS SO TO SPEAK.
I WOULD ATTEST THAT THAT
FIGURES ON TYPICALLY 10% OR
LESS. OF A CONTRACT VALUE SO IF
YOU'RE LOOKING AT OF CONTRACTED
MILLION DOLLARS. YOU'RE LOOKING
AT 60% OF THAT. BUT WERE THERE
ABOUTS BEING ASSOCIATED WITH
LABOR COSTS THE AMOUNT OF THE
VENDOR. PAYS THEIR- EMPLOYEES
TO PERFORM THAT WORK ON THE ON
BEHALF THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA. A 10% OR SO LOWER
LESS. OVERHEAD CHARGE TO THE
VENDOR THE BALANCE THE 30% IS
THAT AMOUNT I WAS DESCRIBED
EARLIER THIS THIS A- CRUDE BY
VIRTUE OF. TRAINING ED
SHEERAN'S. PERSON REQUIREMENTS.
AND SO FORTH. VICE TRAINING
EQUIPMENT AND THE AND THOSE
PARDON MY LACK OF. LACK OF
EXPERTISE IN HIS THAT'S NOT
CONSIDERED OVERHEAD. RIGHT
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S WOULD
YOU WOULD YOU CATEGORIZE THOSE
KINDS OF EXPENSES WHEN I'M
SORRY WHEN I'M TALKING ABOUT.
OVERHEAD CENTER TALKING ABOUT
THE COST THAT THE VENDOR HAS TO
PERFORM THE CONTRACT MEANS
TOWARDS THAT OF THE FORTY
PERCENT. NON LABOR IN YOUR
RIGHT. BUT THE BUT THE 10%
OVERHEAD OR OR PROFIT IS THE
CHARGE THE THEY RECEIVE. FOR
ACTUALLY BRING IN EMPLOYEES AND
PROVIDING THEM TO UNIVERSITY
THAT'S THAT'S THE COST WE PAY
FOR THAT. THE BALANCE ARE
THINGS THAT WE THE 30% OR THE
THINGS THAT WE FACTOR INTO
THOSE CONTRACTS. TO ENSURE THAT
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
DOESN'T PAY FOR THE EQUIPMENT
THAT'S THE WHOLE PURPOSE OF
CONTRACT OUT FOR SPECIALIZED
EQUIPMENT WE DON'T HAVE TO.
PURCHASE AND MAINTAIN.
EXPENSIVE EQUIPMENT WHETHER
IT'S FOR. TREE TRIMMING
PURPOSES. WASHING WINDOWS OR
WHATNOT THOSE ARE THINGS THAT
WE DON'T USE ON A DAILY BASIS
AND SO THEREFORE WE SHOULD
PURCHASE THEM IN. AND MAINTAIN
THEM. BUT EDITION SUPPLIES
WOULD BE CLEANING SUPPLIES OR
OTHERWISE. PRUNING SHEARS THOSE
TYPES OF THINGS. OR THE OTHER
OF THE BALLOTS. HOSE THINGS
WILL CONTINUE THE UNIVERSITY
WILL CONTINUE THESE SPEND MONEY
ON THOSE. IF THEY'RE NOT
CONTAINED IN THE CONTRACT
VALUE. SO MY POINT IS AGAIN
REGARDING THE GYMNAST. OPINION
IS THAT THOSE COSTS WILL
CONTINUE TO BE BORNE BY THE
UNIVERSITY. IN ADDITION TO. THE
WAGE COMPONENT. AND THE BENEFIT
COMPONENT THAT WILL NEED TO
EMPLOY WE'VE NOT WOULD NOT.
HIDDEN BEHIND THIS AT ALL WE'VE
NOT BEEN UNCLEAR ABOUT THIS.
FOLKS WHO ARE ON UNIVERSITY
PAYROLL UNIVERSITY PLEASE MAKE
MORE THAN CONTACTED STAFF. IT
IS THE CASE THAT PRESENT
APARTADO ESTABLISHED A FAIR
WAGE FOR WORK MINIMUM WAGE
PROGRAM A FEW YEARS AGO. TO
ENSURE THAT CONTACT STAFF ALL
STAFF FOR THAT MATTER BUT
CERTAINLY CONTACT STAFF. WOULD
EARN MORE. THAN MINIMUM WAGE
FIFTEEN DOLLARS PER HOUR HAS
BEEN IN PLACE SINCE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. BUT THE AMOUNT THE
UNIVERSITY EMPLOYEES EARN IS
MORE THAN THAT SO THAT'S THE
WAY EACH COMPONENT IT'S ABOUT A
25% INFLATOR AGAIN WE'VE BEEN
USING FOR ABOUT FIVE YEARS NOW.
IN ADDITION ON THE BENEFITS
AGAIN TO THE EXTENT WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO BE VERY DEFENSIBLE
AND VERY CONSERVATIVE. WE'VE
BEEN PUTTING TOGETHER ABOUT IT
WE'VE BEEN PUTTING OUT OF 30%
INFLATOR ON BENEFITS MAKE MY
COLLEAGUES HERE FROM THE CAMPUS
WILL TELL YOU THAT. BENEFITS
USUALLY ABOUT AT LEAST 40% OR
MORE OF THE OVERALL VALUE OF A
OF A WAGE. WE EVEN AT 30% FOR
THE SAKE OF NOT. APPEARING TO
BE JACQUI NUMBERS OF INFLATING
SO IT'S THOSE TWO COMPONENTS
THAT WE BELIEVE WOULD BE ON TOP
OF THAT'S WHAT IT THE QUAIDS TO
THE ONCE EVERY TWO POINT SIX.
AND THOSE BE ON TOP OF THOSE
OTHER. ELEMENTS OF THE CONTRACT
WE BE BEHOLDEN TO PAY. AND IF I
COULD. GO AHEAD I JUST SO I'M
SORRY SO IT'S ONCE A TWO POINT
SIX IN YOUR MIND OR TO. IT'S
EVEN MORE THAN THAT IT'S ONE
THIRTY TWO POINT SIX PLUS. IT'S
ONE THIRTY TWO POINT SIX PLUS
TO THE EXTENT THAT WE WERE
TAPPED TO BRING THOSE. SERVICES
IN HOUSE WE MAY HAVE TO.
PROVIDE FOR THE EQUIPMENT CELLS
MAY HAVE TO PURCHASE SO WHAT IS
WHAT IS THAT IN IN YOUR- THAT
NUMBER WE'VE NOT QUANTIFIED.
AND THAT'S HOW WE'VE OF THE
ORDER OF MAGNITUDE. I MEAN GIVE
ANY SENSE HERE. PRUNING SHEARS
IT SAID I THINK I THINK YOU'RE
CERTAINLY SYSTEM WIDE INTO THE
LOW MILLIONS BUT- IT'S BEEN
VERY DIFFICULT FOR US TO PUT
ADDITIONAL NUMBER ON THAT SO
WHEN YOU. GET BEFORE A FLOOR
VOTE IS THAT CERTAINLY. BECAUSE
I MEAN IN MY MIND YOU GOT THE
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR HERE AS
THE AUTHOR. IF THERE'S A DELTA
TO MEET TO MAKE THIS THE TO
SETTLE THIS ONCE AND FOR ALL
THEN THAT SEEMS LIKE. AT LEAST
WORTH DOING SOME MATH AND
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THAT WOULD
ENTAIL END. AND I GUESS. YEAH I
MEAN THE REAL QUESTION I HAVE
IS ARE THESE. THESE X. X. THE
STATUTORY EXCEPTIONS THOUGH. AS
THESE ACTIONS LIKE DOES THAT
COVER THE SCOPE OF WORK THAT
THAT YOUR CONCERNED YOU WON'T
LIKE IT SEEMS LIKE THEY EVEN
PERMIT US ROOM TO STILL GO TO
THE SPECIAL EVENT WORK AND THE
LANDSCAPING WORK. WITHIN THE
CONTEXT THE BILL THAT WE HAVE
SET TO SEEK IT IN LAW. BUT IT
IS YOUR MATH DRIVEN BY AN
ASSUMPTION THAT WE WOULDN'T
TAKE ANY OF THOSE EXCEPTIONS.
YOU SEE I'M SAYING YEAH OUR OUR
VIEW IS THAT THOSE EXEMPTIONS
IF ALL FIVE WERE TO BE APPROVED
AS THEY'RE WRITTEN ON THE PAGE
TODAY THAT THOSE WOULD ACCOUNT
TO PROVIDE FOR PERHAPS MAYBE
FIVE PERCENT. OF THE OVERALL
AMOUNT OF CONTRACTING OUT
ACTIVITIES OCCUR IN A GIVEN
YEAR AND SO WHILE THE
EXEMPTIONS ARE ARE SOME
FLEXIBILITY THE PROBLEM IS THE
OTHER 95% IS THE OTHER. SELECT
PROHIBITION YEAH LIKE WHAT
OTHER STUFF WELL THERE'S ALL
THE VARIETY OF ISSUES TAKE
PLACE IN THE HOSPITAL AND ARE
NOT NECESSARILY DRIVEN BY AN
EMERGENCY. I THINK THE DOCTOR
WAS TESTIFYING THAT THERE'S
CIRCUMSTANCES OCCUR THROUGHOUT
THE YEAR THROUGHOUT THE WEEK
WHERE PATIENT ACUITY PATIENTS
SEVERITY FLUCTUATES AND MAYBE
WANT TO JUMP IN HERE BUT IT
SAYS WHICH MAY INCLUDE ENSURING
THE CONTINUOUS OPERATIONS OF
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS AND
PROVIDING MEDICAL CARE TO
ADDRESS LIFE THREATENING
SITUATIONS DURING AN EMERGENCY.
COMMA FOR NO LONGER THE ACTUAL
DURATION OF THAT CIRCUMSTANCE
EAT IT IT SEEMS TO. AT LEAST
ONE ADDRESS CONTINUOUS
OPERATIONS IN THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES BUT- WHAT'S THE-
BUT THE ISSUE I THINK THE
QUESTION IS AN EMERGENCY IN AN
EMERGENCY ROOM SITUATION BUT IS
NOT LIMITED TO WITH THE WITH
THE CHAIR SUGGEST SORRY I THINK
WE WOULD ARGUE THAT EMERGENCY
ROOM SITUATION OR EVEN A
GENERAL HOSTILE SITUATION UP.
EMERGENCIES. IT'S EVERYDAY'S
NOT EMERGENCY EVERY DAY IS JUST
THE STANDARD. ROUTINE IT'S
REQUIRED IN HOSPITAL TO CARE
FOR PATIENTS YOU WOULDN'T BE IN
OTHER WORDS NIMBLE ENOUGH TO
SEARCH THEY COULD YOU WOULDN'T
BE THEY ANTICIPATE THE
EMERGENCY SO EVEN IF YOU ADDED
A THORNY IN SOME SENSE TO DO IT
YOU COULDN'T. THIS EXEMPTION AS
OUTLINED IN THIS BILL AT THIS
POINT DOESN'T PROVIDE THE
LIMITS DOESN'T BY THE-
APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OF
FLEXIBILITY TO CONDUCT THE
DAILY AFFAIRS THAT. REQUIRED IN
A HOSPITAL OR ON THE CAMPUS.
CAN I JUST BEFORE I WRAP UP AND
THANK YOU FOR ALL FOR THE
INDULGENCE HERE BUT JUST FROM.
ADDRESS ME OR THE AUTHOR'S
PERSPECTIVE. HOW DO YOU WHAT
WHAT IS THE WHAT IS THE FUTURE
OF SAY THAT EMERGENCY ROOM LOOK
LIKE TO YOU. UNDER THIS EQUAL
EMPLOYMENT. REGIME ACTIVELY
WALK ME THROUGH THAT SAME KIND
OF CIRCUMSTANCE OR HAVE LIKE
HOW IT IS ORGANIZED SORT OF
CONTEXT WE CAN ACTUALLY MAKE IT
BETTER BECAUSE I GUESS IT'S NOT
EVEN WORKING RIGHT NOW SO IT'S
NOT IS IT YES WELL THAT I THINK
THAT'S A THERE IS NOTHING THAT
THE DOCTOR SAID THAT I DISAGREE
WITH BUT THAT'S UNDER THE
CURRENT REGIME WE HAVE THIS
PROBLEM WHERE THEY HAVE
CONTRACTED WORKERS WHERE THEY
HAVE FLEXIBILITY WHERE THEY
UTILIZE CONTRACT WORKERS SO
STAFFING ISSUES WILL ALWAYS BE
AN ISSUE WHETHER THOSE ARE
CONTRACTED STAFF OR EMPLOYEES
OF THE UNIVERSITY I THINK
THAT'S CLEAR. WHEN YOU BRING UP
A CASE THAT IS CURRENTLY
PROBLEMATIC I MEAN UNLESS SHE'S
ARE AND I DIDN'T HEAR THIS
UNLESS SHE'S ARGUING THAT IN
FACT WE CONTRACT OUT MORE WORK
THAT WOULD DEFEAT I THINK THE
UC'S KIND OF POSITION AND ANY
ASSURANCES WE HAVE FOR THE
FUTURE AND PERHAPS IT DOES
HIGHLIGHT. HI THIS HAS TO BE.
IN TRYING TO THE CONSTITUTION
AND WE NEED TO DEAL WITH THIS
IS BECAUSE THERE ARE ALWAYS
GOING TO BE THESE TYPES OF
PRESSURES NOT JUST THAT YOU SEE
BUT ANY HOSPITAL. IN DEALING
WITH STAFF TEEN. AS APPROPRIATE
STAFFING LEVELS IS SOMETHING WE
DEAL WITH IT HOSPITALS I MEAN
WE DO A LOT BILLS ON THAT SO
OBVIOUSLY IT'S AN ISSUE. I
DON'T THINK THAT HAS ANYTHING
TO DO WITH THE CONTRACTED OUT
ISSUE I THINK THAT THE LANGUAGE
THAT THE CHAIR HAS. OFFERED UP
AND WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
PROVIDES MAXIMUM FLEXIBILITY
FOR. FOR HOSPITALS YOU KNOW IN
IN SITUATIONS WHERE WE MAY
NEED. MORE AT CONTRACT BUT I'M
NOT IT I FEEL LIKE WHERE WE
HAVE TWO DIFFERENT ARGUMENTS
GOING ON ONE WHICH WE ALWAYS
NEED TO ADDRESS DOES YOU SEE ME
MORE MONEY YES I THINK WE DEAL
WITH THIS EVERY SINGLE YEAR. IS
THAT DIFFERENT THAN HOW THEY'RE
USING THAT MONEY. AND HOW WE'RE
TREATING. WORKERS AND PEOPLE
WHETHER THEY WORK FOR THE
UNIVERSITY VERSUS A CONTRACTOR.
THERE LEYVA ONSTAR CENTERS
RIGHT MY FINAL POINT WOULD JUST
BE I COULDN'T AGREE MORE THAN
WE'VE BEEN STARVING THE YOU SEE
FOR TOO LONG. AND THAT'S FOR
STUDENTS PROFESSORS WORKERS IS
THE GRACE PUBLIC UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM IN THE WORLD AND I'M-
I'M. VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
FUTURE THIS SYSTEM ADDED
STARTING TO ATROPHY AND FALL
APART ON THE CAPITAL SIDE
PERSONNEL STUDENTS YOU KNOW THE
FIFTY PRESSURES OUT THERE SO.
I'M I'M I'M SUPPORTING THE
MEASURE. AND I WANT TO SEE SOME
MORE INFORMATION BEFORE THE
FLOOR I REALLY I HOPE WE CAN
GET SOME SOME BETTER MATH AND
REALLY KEEP US INFORMED ABOUT
WHAT THE FINANCIAL COMMITMENT
UNDERLYING THIS VOTE IS I
GUESS. RIGHT IF WE'RE GONNA GO
ALL THE WAY WITH ISN'T GOING TO
CONSTITUTION WHAT ARE WE
OBLIGATING OURSELVES TO AND HOW
DO WE GET REAL ABOUT THAT IS A
LEGISLATURE SAY OKAY WE'RE
GONNA STEP UP AND DO OUR PART
WE'RE PUSH YOU DO YOU DO YOUR
PART AND WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE
TO ME I MEAN IF I CAN GO IN
THIS EYES WIDE OPEN. ON THAT
MATH IT'S A VERY DIFFERENT VOTE
THEN. THEN JUST ON YOU KNOW A
COMPLETE YOUR YOUR COMPETING
YEAH YOUR COMPETING SUPPOSITION
ABOUT WHAT'S UNDERLYING GYMNAST
AND WE NEED SOMETHING MORE TO
GO ON HERE WE KNOW THAT IT IS
JUST CAME TO YOU SO YOU CAN
TAKE A LONG TIME TO DO THE
HOMEWORK BUT THAT WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL ANY OTHER. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR HOMEWORK ON THIS AND-
YEAH THERE LEYVA. THE CHAIR OF
THE I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUES
THAT WE ARE STARVING THE UC'S
WE COULD PROBABLY GIVE THEM
MORE MONEY BUT I THINK IT'S THE
WAY THEY SPEND THEIR MONEY THAT
IS SOMETIMES OF THE ISSUE I
JUST WANT TO REINFORCE WHAT THE
AUTHOR SAID IN TRYING THIS IN
THE CONSTITUTION IS A STATEMENT
OF OUR BELIEFS AND OUR VALUES I
THINK THAT IS ONE ISSUE BUT I
THINK THE OTHER ISSUE IS AS
SOMEONE WHO NEGOTIATED
CONTRACTS FOR A VERY LONG TIME.
SOMETIMES PEOPLE DON'T DO THE
RIGHT THING TO FORCE THEM TO DO
THE RIGHT THING THE UC HAS HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO THE RIGHT
THING FOR MANY MANY YEARS AND
FOR WHATEVER REASON HAS CHOSEN
NOT TO AT THE BARGAINING TABLE
WE ALWAYS HEAR ABOUT THE COSTS
AND WHATNOT NOT ONE OF THE
COMPANIES THAT I BARGAINED WITH
FOR ALL THOSE YEARS EVER WENT
OUT OF BUSINESS THEY ONLY
INCREASE THEIR PROFITS ARE ONLY
MAKING MORE AND MORE MONEY BUT
EVERY TIME WE NEGOTIATE IT'S
ALWAYS ABOUT THE MONEY IT'S
NEVER ABOUT THE PEOPLE WHEN ARE
WE GOING TO MAKE IT ABOUT THE
PEOPLE WHEN WE'RE GONNA MAKE
ABOUT THE WORKERS WHO ARE
TRYING TO FEED THEIR FAMILY.
THE WORKERS WHO WOULD LOVE
MAYBE SOMEBODY FOR THEIR CHILD
TO GET TO GO TO THIS
INSTITUTION IT'S HIGH TIME THAT
WE DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT AND IN
TRYING IN THE CONSTITUTION IT'S
JUST THE RIGHT THING TO DO SO I
URGE AN AYE VOTE HERE AND ON
THE SENATE FLOOR BUT I WILL
LEAVE THAT UP TO YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU. READY
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU CENTER
LEYVA. IT JUST TOOK A COUPLE
OTHER. COMMENTS AND CONCERNS.
ALL OF US HERE ARE PROUD OF THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA I BELIEVE
I'M PARTICULARLY PROUD IN MY
FAMILY I HAVE ONE CHILD TO
GRADUATE MUCIUS BE TO THE
GRADUATED FROM BERKELEY LAW I
GRADUATED FROM UCLA Là MISS.
IS MR WOLINSKY IS HEARD ME SAY
BEFORE THAT UP MY HEART IS UCLA
MY MONEY'S BEEN AT UC BERKELEY.
SO. SO BUT ALTHOUGH WE'RE ALL
PROUD AND THIS IS A AS SIMILAR
STERN POINTS OUT SOMETHING THAT
IS. AN EXAMPLE FOR LEASE THE
UNITED STATES WE HAVE COMPETING
INTERESTS WE HAVE COMPETING
RESPONSIBILITIES WE
RESPONSIBILITIES STUDENTS TO
COME THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
MAKE SURE THEY GET A FIRST
CLASS EDUCATION. WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO OUR EMPLOYEES
WERE AN EMPLOYER AND THEN
RESPONSIBLY NOT JUST TO BE ABLE
TO GET SORTED TO THE LOWEST
COMMON DENOMINATOR BUT TO BE AN
EXAMPLE FOR OTHERS. AS A
RESPONSIBLE EMPLOYER. WE HAVE A
WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO THE
PATIENTS AS YOU POINT OUT
DOCTOR THAT WE RESPONSIBILITY
THE PATIENTS THAT COME THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA FOR
TREATMENT. WE RESPONSIBILITY
TAXPAYERS AND BALANCING ALL
THOSE RESPONSIBILITIES
SOMETIMES IS DIFFICULT
SOMETIMES CREATES TENSIONS.
THIS IS AN EFFORT TO ADJUST
THAT BALANCE OF I THINK IT'S A
WORK IN PROGRESS I APPRECIATE
YOU ACCEPTING THE MOMENT WE
PROPOSE. I THINK IS GOING TO BE
OTHER WORK THAT'S GOING TO BE
DONE ON THIS ACA BEFORE IT.
ULTIMATELY COMES OF THE FLOOR
THE SENATE I HAVE A HISTORY IN
THIS AREA ALTHOUGH I'M ONLY
THIRTY YEARS OLD TWENTY EIGHT
YEARS AGO WHEN I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY. I ACTUALLY WORKED ON
THIS ISSUE WITH YOU SEE I WHEN
THE GROUNDS KEEPERS ARE ABOUT
TO GO ON STRIKE BECAUSE OF
DIFFERENT ISSUES AND WITH
CHANCELLOR PELT ISN'T SOME YOU
MAY REMEMBER PRESENT HELPS AND
IT WAS A CHANCE FOR THE TIME.
WE WORKED OUT A COMPROMISE THAT
WAS ACCEPTABLE AT LEAST FOR
THE- OF FOR THE NEXT DECADE. SO
I AM GOING TO SUPPORT THIS I
THINK THAT THIS IS. AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE BUT I ALSO
THINK IT IS IT IS REMAINS A
WORK IN PROGRESS. SO WITHOUT
FURTHER DISCUSSION FOOD RATIONS
CENTER LEYVA MOVES. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS IN A DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY. I'M SORRY OF. THE
LOOMING IT'S ALSO IT'S LIKE
CLOSE THAT'S OKAY I'LL BE BRIEF
I ALSO A UCLA LAW GRADUATE I
HAD MY DAUGHTER AT UCLA MEDICAL
CENTER AND I THINK THE AFFINITY
WE HAVE FOR YOU SEE. ALL OF US
IN THIS BODY IT IS CLEAR. I
ALSO HAVE AN AFFINITY FOR EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY AND I THINK WE
CAN'T. LOVE YOU SEE SO MUCH
THAT WE SUGGEST THAT THEY'RE
EXEMPT FROM OUR PRINCIPLES OF
BASIC DIGNITY AND EQUALITY. SO
WITH THAT THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I ALSO WANT TO POINT
OUT AND I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
IN THIS I'M SURE WILL BE AN
ONGOING DISCUSSION ABOUT
OVERHEAD AND TRAINING AND- AS
AS THE CONTRACTS DECREASE THEY
RUN OUT BECAUSE WE IT'LL- TAKE
OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS. IN AND
PEOPLE ARE IN SOURCED IF YOU
WILL THOSE COSTS GO DOWN AND WE
KNOW THAT IN SO. A LOT OF COST
RIGHT NOW ARE DUPLICATIVE.
TRAINING HAPPENS WHETHER YOU'RE.
EMPLOYEE OR OR YOU'RE NOT
THERE'S OFTEN SAVINGS AND SCALE.
LONG TERM ACQUIRING THE TYPE
OF. THINGS THAT YOU NEED TO DO
YOUR JOB WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
OUTSOURCE RADIOLOGY TAX THEY
BRING IN THEIR OWN MRI. HEY WE
STILL HAVE THAT EQUIPMENT SO A
LOT OF THIS BECOMES A LESSER OF
A COST IN OVERHEAD AND I THINK
WHAT WE FOUND FROM THE AUDITOR
FROM THE FORMER TO. DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE DIRECTOR IS THAT IN
FACT MAYBE WE HAVEN'T BEEN SO
HONEST ABOUT THE COST OF
OUTSOURCING AND THAT THIS
MEASURE COULD ACTUALLY HELP US
HELP YOU SEE SAVE SOME MONEY.
AND SO WITH THAT I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE
LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH ALL OF YOU ON THIS AS A
MALE HOPEFULLY MOVES TO
PREPARATIONS AND TO THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT MA'AM
SECTOR. MOTION IS BE ADOPTED
ARE REFERRED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE NUMBER
NUMBER I NIELSEN NIELSEN NO
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE LEYVA
LEYVA AYE STERN STERN NINE. THE
APPROPRIATIONS THANK YOU ALL
THANK YOU ALL FOR TRAVELING
WITH THIS IS YOUR TRAVEL. WE
ARE. WE SENATE ELECTIONS
CONSORTIUM MEMBERS IS A JOURNEY
THANK YOU